that said  you've also showed appreciation for the  greatest language  um ever that i think everyone agrees  is lisp um well this was definitely on  my list of the greatest ones that have  have um existed is that number one or  i mean um are you i mean  you know that you know the thing is that  it's that you you know  i wouldn't put it number one no is it  the parentheses what uh  um what do you love what do you  not love about lisp um  well i guess the number one thing to not  love about it is so freaking many  parentheses yeah um  on the on the love thing is you know out  of those  tons of parentheses you actually get an  interesting language structure  and i've always thought that there was a  friendlier version of lisp  hiding out there somewhere um  but i've never really spent much time  thinking about it thinking about it  you